[Evans] Let's think about how to define union.
We need to make a procedure that takes 2 lists as its inputs.
We'll call the lists p and q.
To define union we want to modify p by adding elements from q.
We should remember that append operation does that.
It adds a new element to a list.
So we're going to use append to add elements from q to p.
To define union we need to go through all the elements in q.
Check for each element whether it already exists in p.
If it does, we do nothing.
If it doesn't, then we add it to p.
So we'll use a for-loop.
We need to make sure that we loop through the elements of q.
Those are the ones that we want to add to p.
For each element we need to test whether or not it's already in p,
so we check to make sure the element is not already in p.
If this is true, that means e is not in p,
and we want to add it.
To add e to p, we use append.